we all remember eating Mr Noodles pretty
much every single day breakfast lunch
and dinner as college kids did you ever
eat them just raw in the world that was
like the only way I ate them but today
I'm going to show you how to make them
into a hunger cushion combo step number
one I'm using bone broth for some extra
flavor and a lot of extra protein as
well
noodle them
so how come you didn't put the pocket in
I just put enough chicken flavor in the
bone broth I'm gonna add a little splash
of coconut aminos and some sesame oil as
well
now I've just got some leftover
stir-fried veg from last night's dinner
and some rotisserie chicken the little
hard-boiled egg and some sesame seeds we
got protein in the bone broth Chicken
and the Egg we've got lots of fiber in
the sauteed veg plus we've got some
healthy fats in the sesame oil and
sesame seeds on top and the Egg I'm
pretty excited about this and it
literally took me five minutes to make
here you go Freddy uh I'm good I think
I'm just gonna eat them raw what